yesterday Tim the tap man dr. Lupo and
lyric all announced that they've signed
exclusive contracts to remain streaming
on Twitch this is just the latest in a
series of escalating announcements that
have been the biggest news in live
streaming over the past few months as I
speak the bidding war continues and
we've got a lot to cover today so let's
get into it before someone [ __ ] signs
with snapchat or something ok so before
we dive into the news today's episode is
in support of Susan G Komen ribbon race
challenge so after you finish watching
this video instead of scrolling down to
the comments and telling me I look like
I'm crying for the 50th time log on to
fortnight and support a good cause so
the way to do that is scroll down hit
the link in the description below
they'll have a donation page for you to
donate right away
and then you'll get the link to this map
and you can try to beat the best time
once you're done the map send us a clip
on social media or link it in the
comments below and see if you can beat
our best times and obviously it's not
going to be that hard if you're one of
the viewers that beat my time will pin
your name in the comments below be sure
to stay tuned to the end of the video
where you can watch me embarrass myself
trying to run the challenge look I don't
need to tell you that supporting cancer
research is an important thing so go
help them out now let's get back to the
news ok so a lot has happened since the
last time I sat on this stool and
rambled to you about various streamers
signing with various platforms for
multi-million dollar deals but let's
start with what's brand new from
yesterday at 1:00 p.m. Eastern Time o
110 if you're Tim the tab man and you
can't figure out how to get your own
video to work lyric Tim and Lupo all
announced that they'd sign deals to stay
streaming on Twitch now the future
what's next well if I have my way
nothing but more of the same
aggressively mediocre gameplay terrible
jokes and helping those in need in the
most effective way that I possibly can
the best part is that I'm not gonna make
it any harder for you because I've
officially resigned with twitch a lot of
people have been talking about platform
deals and this and that
where's Tim the tab man gonna end up
after a lot of thought and a lot of
consideration I'm happy to announce I
was staying on twitch.tv slash Tim the
tap man here that Kevin we're not going
anywhere I remember where I was I was on
Twitch and that's where I'm staying and
given all the news over the last few
months this was a huge announcement and
a big deal for twitch all three of these
creators are signed to a talent agency
called loading and as far as I can tell
that's the only reason for the sinking
of the announcements to me this is major
news Tim and Lupo are not only huge
names but they're definitely the kind of
people that twitch likes to put on
display for their brand the kind of guys
that a faceless company like Amazon who
owns twitch love to be associated with
it's the the top tier streamers the all
the way down to the smallest communities
it does not matter who you are if this
has not inspired you please at the end
of the day remember this one phrase that
will get me out of bed every single day
to do these streams it will get me up in
the morning on December 21st for the
next round of bill gives cancer it'll
get me out there every single time [ __ ]
cancer and everything that it does and
to me that obviously makes them hugely
important to hang on to come on that
with they're more than 20,000 combined
concurrent viewers rigorous daily
streaming schedules and huge brand deals
yeah these guys are pretty big now
before we dive a little bit deeper if
you're new to this [ __ ] let me catch you
up in the least boring way possible
ninja sign with mixer and the floodgates
opened all of a sudden the idea of an
exclusive streaming contract with seven
figures on it was a reality and since
then NIC mercs signed back with twitch
shroud jump to mixer as well encouraged
ad while he signed with YouTube I'm not
leaving hundred thieves
I'm joining you too
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what should do you it coming a moose and
I spent like the last eight weeks
refreshing my Twitter feed to make sure
I don't miss the next a maker thrown in
this fight for all the best broadcasters
but since we last spoke there's even
more to update you on a new broadcaster
has jumped into the ring Facebook over
the past few weeks Facebook has
announced the exclusive signings of
smash star zero and card gamer
extraordinaire disguise tones nope I'm
movin to Facebook gaming check me out
there
bye so the announcement is that I'm
going to be moving over to Facebook
gaming as my main streaming platform now
over the course of this entire saga each
and every move it comes with its own set
of intrigue and interest but none have
surprised me quite as much as this one
not necessarily the names themselves
being signed because obviously these
guys are great streamers but the fact
that Facebook is looking to get in the
ring and fight with these established
broadcast Giants now as you guys might
know Facebook actually already tried to
get into gaming back in 2018 when they
bought the rights to ESL's csgo events
and their dota 2 events and that was a
huge [ __ ] failure Facebook has signed
two guys in toast and 0 who comes
strapped with their very own very
specific communities which seems to me
like exactly the kind of streamers you'd
want if you were looking to draw in
viewership to an otherwise untested
platform these guys have their very own
sort of cult-like following and I think
that's good for Facebook another big
signing headline was a walk who signed
with mixer and what was maybe my
favorite of all these announcement
videos
so that's a total of six people in the
last few weeks that have signed on the
dotted line to continue this madness but
now that we're done recapping the news
I'd like to hone in on one specific
announcement Lupo's in honestly
quintessential lupo fashion he dared to
say a lot of things in conjunction with
the announcement that a lot of other
streamers have chat awake over the last
year or so Lupo has really grown into a
kind of dad figure for twitch literally
and figure he's where we go to for
advice a sort of voice box for the
average streamer a link between all the
things we think about twitch and how
they actually are he's never shied away
from telling it like it is and that
didn't change on Tuesday he made the
statement I've been waiting for since
this whole thing started financial
security for myself my family because in
the end there's nothing wrong with
trying to secure the bag you know full
sent into it nobody else would say it
nobody else would would would comment
directly on on what we're doing or or or
that this kind of thing is okay it's
okay to get paid to do your job you all
get paid to do your job
right and if I got lucky enough and just
like the other guys you know more power
to them
- Jack - Tyler - shroud and goth and you
walk and everybody that's jump platforms
good good I hope you you guys all get
more money - I hope everybody gets more
money finally someone said there's
nothing wrong with signing a contract to
get paid and you know like buy a house
or support your family or do all of
those things that well-adjusted people
do on the internet there always seems to
be this same narrative around this type
of thing some voices in the back calling
people sellouts for getting paid to work
sometimes but I was personally stoked to
hear Lupo singers because like he
acknowledged on stream it kind of felt
like someone had to it's just like any
other business on the planet people need
to get paid he also touched on one more
specifically interesting point
there are more viewer hours on Twitch
than any other platform in the world
like is a it is a very blatant very
clear sign that more people watch twitch
than anything else no matter what and I
do mean it when I say that I stayed on
twitch because because of charity this
amazing most sense dude I don't need to
build a damn castle y'all are my castle
I've already built that I'm good
we bow urged that it was important for
him to stay on Twitch because simply
it's were the most viewership is and in
his case admirably that's a huge deal
because of all the charity work he does
once as many viewers as possible being
able to support those causes but I
actually think it alludes to a larger
conversation that's been sort of looming
in the background of all of this
streamer news is it ultimately a bad
thing to jump ship for a contract and
then lose viewers because of it
according to a stats website called
twitch tracker ninja has been streaming
over the last 14 days on mixer to an
average of over 7,000 viewers at a time
while shroud on mixer has been streaming
to an average of just over 5,000 now for
the size of the platform those numbers
are obviously huge but in comparison to
the average of 41k ninja with streaming
- in July of 2019 on twitch and the 23k
the tribe is streaming - there's
obviously a cost to doing business and I
think that fact services the decisions
made by Tim and Lupo and lyric here the
fact is twitch is where the viewers are
and there is a massive risk associated
with going to another platform even if
it means signing a contract now by no
means am i condemning the decisions made
to go elsewhere
ninja obviously made huge waves started
this whole thing for everyone I decide
you decide with mixer but we've done a
lot of celebrating of those moves on
this show and I think after Lupo alluded
to it in his video there was time to
take a look at the stats there was a lot
going into it right but it really
ultimately felt right to stay on Twitch
alright I got one last point that I want
to talk about this and it's something
that I've alluded to before with each
pass a set of signings it becomes more
and more clear that these companies are
looking for PG streams the heroes and
heroines of live stream fails are
nowhere to be found in all of this news
at least not yet
in fact I think I'd call the roster of
people who
signed over the past few months just
about as safe as it gets from twitch and
it's even common at the cost of
popularity guys like xqc dr.
disrespected t food they all have bigger
following than a lot of the people we've
been talking about but there are also
the kind of streamers who have been
known to get into trouble every now and
then so I'm asking myself is one of
these live streaming platforms gonna
come along and present itself as the
place for all the degenerates to go I
guess we'll find out all right so that's
all we got for the news today but like I
said off the top now you guys get to
watch me run the Susan G Komen ribbon
race challenge and embarrass myself for
charity like I said if you guys want to
run the map and see if you can beat my
horrific gun make sure to make a
donation now in the link below now let's
get into it
challenge one join the fight I should
have played practice games for sure Oh
our camera guy is not impressed the
camera crew is taunting me I'm doing it
Oh finally finish the balloon part
oh we're swimming we're swimming we're
swimming even the director who's never
played a game before that his life is
talking about hey so I'm getting the
sword oh it's the finish line let's go
finally 59 minutes and 34 seconds later
alright guys after what feels like an
absolute eternity in honestly the
hottest room in the score office I
finally finished the Susan G Komen
ribbon race challenge next up I
challenge Colin to see if he can beat my
score thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up art Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages